where people are running in these
detention centers waiting for their
cases to be heard estimate righto para
nosotros Morel meant a bitchy comment a
psychological meant a la parte mizura
I'm a steady steady cuando NOS venimos
es para nosotros que no venom o0 de
homos
[Music]
on any given day in this desolate region
60 miles outside of Phoenix you can find
thousands of immigrants behind bars some
have been locked up for years waiting
for a court hearing trapped in a broken
and backlogged American immigration
system for the past two years
Adela's husband Sergio has been held at
Eloy Detention Center today she invited
me to join her and her two teenage sons
on a visit how have you felt these past
two years without him yo me siento muy
mal por que puede siempre estado con
nosotros el sol su esposa muy
responsible muy buenas posso cuando el
padre y wale LD se puede slow juice Ted
son me medicina ustedes son la fuerza
para salir adelante por que pues yo no
messes / ando si en de semana porque si
que van a venir a la sergio was pulled
over in 2015 by narcotics agents who
accused him of having drugs they didn't
find any but they did discover that he
had re-entered the US illegally after
being deported years ago did you ever
expect that you'd be in this situation
where your husband's in detention and
you have to drive an hour to see him
every couple weeks way Sunu siempre
piensa que pasar esto por que puede en
primer lugar por hacer dokument ah dono
que cualquier momento de pueden para que
pueden deport RCSS at Imola cada uno
Enzo tous like economy most immigrants
in detention are there for minor
nonviolent crimes including falsifying
documents to work detention is temporary
but immigration courts have a backlog of
over half a million cases and that means
people like Sergio can be stuck there
with no end in sight
our cameras weren't allowed inside Eloy
but the four hours I spent in there made
one thing clear
detention feels very much like prison
[Music]
it was a really emotional experience I
can't imagine going every week basically
you go into this room with about ten or
so tables and the minute Adele and her
husband saw each other there was this
big family hug some people were crying
other people were kissing their wives
and kids were clinging on to their dads
that they were just seeing they spread
out the snacks that they've gotten from
the vending machine onto the table on
foil things like microwavable mini
pizzas and various chips Adela was
sitting across from her husband and the
entire time they were holding hands for
the whole hour and her son was sitting
next to his dad and hugging him it was
beautiful and also heartbreaking to see
this family that's been separated come
together for just one hour and you could
tell how much that our meant to all of
them
you know immigrant attention can not
only be heartbreaking but also
debilitating Eloy is run by the private
for-profit company core civic formerly
known as CCA the detention center has
come under fire for spoiled food poor
health care and the highest number of
detainee deaths in the country LIGO
spent over a year in Eloy and he's still
haunted by the experience DME processed
a Ramada cinco messes no meat and Hierro
hasta que yo wolterman ok no puedes ad
or nar esta came a pair our own Calvin
hace me acuerdo something else he'll
never forget is the death of his fellow
detainee hosea hey-zeus DePrima mucho
crea ver sus hijos create a desde el
número para que lebron Juarez a lab Oh
godoh
lo indole ro o y cuando de Guerre o la
cow domi Ramos salud Juarez internal
honest Abed como los cinco minutos el
camino de llegar hola un para medicos
cuando el estado muerto
Jose's death was ruled a suicide the
fifth to take place in Eloy in a decade
a total of 15 immigrants have died there
since 2003 we reached out to Cora Civic
for comment but received no response
undocumented immigrants don't have the
right to an attorney but they can
contract one although many are unable to
just to give you an idea they're close
to 3,000 people
in detention between Florence and Eloy
on any given day and there are only
about seven attorneys here at the
Florence project so it's a huge
discrepancy so the reality is we're not
able to represent the majority of people
would you say that if more people in
detention had access to a lawyer less
people would be deported ultimately yes
the number is something along the lines
of 97% of folks that go through removal
proceedings that don't have an attorney
wound up losing their cases
every year thousands of immigrants like
Adela's husband Sergio are convicted of
illegally re-entering the US after being
deported Sergio plans to represent
himself when he gets his day in court
hey guys it's Deena and I'm on the
us-mexico border make sure you check out
our next video we're gonna cross into
Mexico and show you what life is like
for those deported